[Singing]
Andy Clark approached me a couple years
ago to commission me for this particular
concert and the guidelines were, he said
why don't you write something that is
Christmas-y, wintry, not necessarily
religious. So I chose three texts, three
poems about winter. It conveys a blizzard
in a winter storm and it's a really
great way to start thinking about that
chilly but exciting part of the year.
It's a very festive atmosphere. This will
be a particularly sing-along focused
christmas concert but there's always a
lot of great audience participation
people come to these concerts expecting
to be involved in to be singing with us.
More than just being a Harvard event
it's really a community event too, so in
working with the Snap Choir from
Lexington and making it a free concert
so that's accessible to everyone,
we're really trying to bring this
Christmas spirit that we're creating at
Harvard to both the Harvard community
and the broader Cambridge in Boston
communities. One of the major reasons
that the glee club commission's pieces
in the first place is to create
repertoire for other choirs to use. Not a
whole lot of music necessarily is
written for tenor-based choirs so we're sort of
trying to keep that tradition alive
with our commissions and the same is
really true of RCS' commission, sort
of the other way around, so they're
sort of also contributing to a
repertory tradition that can continue
for years into the future.
[Singing]